let's bring in Frank Isola from the
athletic ESPN's around the horn and uh
he joins us on the program Frank who won
the trade in the short term Dan I think
it's the Lakers because they get Anthony
Davis but the trade was always about one
player long TV with the Lakers and it
was LeBron James rich ball hoping to get
LeBron James you know one more chance at
a title because you know how many you
know top years as LeBron have left to me
you know you're hoping for maybe three
but he did break down this year was it
55 games that he played in so Anthony
Davis a few years and I could find
himself in the same situation he was in
New Orleans the only differences I'll
have an ocean view of that team that's
not that good but also I I mentioned
this last hour that we look at you know
LeBron is being timeless and he's played
he'll be he'll have played 350 more
games than Michael Jordan at the same
age this next season at age 35 you know
eventually
LeBron's not gonna be the best player on
his own team and I think you're right
when you're saying you got a two-year
window here maybe three if and you know
you can bring another title to that that
town in you're 100% right and a very
good website is Basketball Reference
comm because it has everyone stats on
there and go look it LeBron's regular
season games played total minutes and
then go look at his playoff games pretty
soon he's going to approach three full
seasons of playoff games you know three
full NBA seasons of just playoff games
and Danny if you go back to what
happened this season with the Toronto
Raptors one of the most underrated parts
of their of their year was that they
decided because they're trying to do
everything they can to keep Kawhi
Leonard was they played him in 60 games
in those 60 games I'm sorry in those 22
games that he missed they went 17 and 5
that allows them to have home court
advantage in the second round against
Philadelphia they went on that
last-second shot and they had home court
advantage in the NBA Finals
I think players like Kevin Durant who
played 78 games this season wasn't
available except for 12 minutes in the
NBA Finals you're never going to see
these guys play 75 games same thing with
LeBron James and how is he going how are
you going to look at LeBron James and
say we want you to play 75 plus games
then in the playoffs that his agent just
I mean to me Kawhi Leonard now kind of
because everything is a trend and right
now with a wait Kawhi Leonard and the
Raptors handle this I think other teams
and I think the Laker certainly with
LeBron James are going to do the same
thing that's what right Anthony Davis
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they fill out the rest of that roster
because I think there might be 15 to 20
games next season when LeBron is not on
the court yeah this whole load
management I I get it you know kawaii'
basically was saying this is what I'm
gonna give you because I want to give
you more when the playoffs start LeBron
was doing load management this year I I
don't know at what point a player can
say hey I'm taking off because of load
management I don't know like you have to
be a superstar to be able to say this
but I do think the Commissioner is gonna
have a problem on his hands that you
know he might be looking at shortening
this season
instead of having this load management
issue here what do you think about that
III agree with you and because he has
stretched out the season few
back-to-backs no more four games in five
nights and you know I think Adam silver
there's a lot of good things I think
this idea of having some goofy in season
tournament like they have in England
with the FA Cup I mean come on you know
the FA Cup works because it seemed like
Wimbledon who's in the third division
gets to play Manchester you know it's a
big thing I'm gonna go play the Erie
BayHawks and it's gonna be a big deal
for the NBA teams the NBA players we
can't even get them to play in 82 games
now we're gonna have a in season
tournament no but I know like to try to
create some tradition I don't like you
know I wasn't threatening that way
towards shortening the season because
everything's getting better you know the
medicine and all these teams you know
have guys that monitor their diets and
they have sweet coaches and everything
like that yet everyone's getting hurt
LeBron played all 82 last year and then
the 22 playoff games this year he made
it to 55 and Kevin Durant how could he
not be sitting there thinking man I
played 78 games during a regular season
I missed the Conference Finals I missed
all the 12 minutes in the NBA if I was
gonna end up automatic my achilles and
here's Cole on Leonard who never played
think about this he never played more
than eight games in a row at any point
during the season with the Toronto
Raptors they had 13 sets of back to
backs he never played in both games of a
back-to-back so they
their plan you could hate it and fans
have every right to hate it dan Patrick
goes to see the Rolling Stones play and
if the guy does not the lead singer be
picked up so it's the same thing when
you go see the Toronto Raptors play but
today they're having a parade so guess
what it were if you could put somebody
on the Lakers now aside from you know in
addition to Anthony Davis who would be
the one player that they have to have I
think they need someone that could knock
down an outside shot you want to make
that Kemba Walker you want to make it
you know maybe a notch below that
somebody like JJ Redick I think that's
going to be the most important thing
because I think Anthony Davis with
LeBron is obviously going to be a
dynamic pairing good they need guys that
could knock down perimeter shots and
then they have the money to do it for
their credit you know in a year where it
doesn't look like Kevin Durant and klay
Thompson are going to play the Western
Conference is completely wide open like
then were Portland even Oklahoma City
the Rockets should be excited but they
seem to be a little dysfunctional the
Lakers have a chance to go for it here
but they need to get to an outside
shooting so it's not a guy if it soccer
they're got like Kemba Walker maybe you
know a notch to Dodgers down something
like JJ Redick a guy that could you know
open things up for LeBron James and
Bradley David talking to Frank Isola of
the athletic Kia spins around the horn
well we have daryl morey on the show
tomorrow and i brought up houston i I
think they're in a great situation now I
don't know if I would have said that you
know a month ago but it feels like with
the West a little bit in a state of flux
right now Houston is fully assembled I
mean I don't like the Chris Paul
contract here but do they trade some of
these assets or would you just go into
battle next year with the lineup that
you have I mean I hate to keep saying
this but I agree with you I don't
understand why everyone that's over
what's happened in the last two years
they lost to the best team and if you
know Durant had been available for the
finals I think the Golden State Warriors
would have won I think where they lost
that series was when Durant got hurt
there was a bit of a shock that were 14
minutes left in that game and that's
when the Rockets had a chance to win
that game because they've taken a 3-2
lead and I really think they would have
been in the driver's seat for Game six
of the last 14 minutes of Game five in
game six the second half when Steph
Curry what not you're still losing to a
great team you're not getting you know
knocked out in the first
by a lunar seasoned team I think it's
good a complete overreaction I think
they're right they're on the cusp now so
that'll have been there you know right
they're on the cusp of couple of times
they went out and got a guy like Kawhi
Leonard I don't think they can afford
and any way to get a player like that
but I think everything has changed now
with Durant and klay Thompson why can't
the Rockets who have been in theory the
second best team in the Western
Conference the last two years why can't
it be them
next season Harden is still a terrific
player and of Chris Paul could stay
healthy back on what to me that's always
gonna be the big issue with that and
Chris Paul stay open if he can I think
it's you know it's funny they see their
own worst enemy at that at this point
because without their inner klay
Thompson the Rockets are just as good of
a bad as anybody else can throw an NBA
Finals had the Knicks been the biggest
losers in the offseason it certainly
feels like that I felt that way I was up
in Toronto for Game five and after the
game I don't like there were three teams
that were really sad Toronto for blowing
the game in the final 30 minutes the
Warriors for losing their best player
for probably a year and then the next
because they were hoping to get Kevin
Durant now they could still go out and
sign him but yeah how can you justify
that if you're the Knicks because by the
time Kevin Durant plays he'd be 32
having missed a year coming back from a
torn Achilles and you're an organization
that's one one playoff series in the
last 18 years and you you know you lived
through the contracts of Antonio McDyess
Alan Houston Amar'e Stoudemire guys you
have a lot of money too that were in
turn you know I you could say you know
all the information I got is great you
think he's gonna return to be a great
player be careful with that extinction
is it did sound like there was a good
chance that he would go there but you
know what the mix of something they
could fall back on it hurt them dan is a
fan made the trade for porzingis you
have porzingis joining the team you
haven't still on the team and you it
looks like you'd have RJ Barrett coming
on board and that would really give the
fans something to hold on to as opposed
to wait one more year and we'll get
Kevin Durant I think that's like a silly
way to go about it but I think the
Knicks looking to kind of sound of
something here and to save face I think
they'll go all-in to try to get Kevin
Durant I think he'd be crazy to do it I
think they'd be crazy okay yeah just you
brought up porzingis i wondered about
this and i've been wondering about it
maybe you can set me straight
but if the Knicks still had porzingis
and and durant with that scenario was
still in in play
you could have traded porzingis to New
Orleans and then been involved in the
Anthony Davis deal right that that's
right that's absolutely right you
definitely could have done that yeah so
on the one hand they got some assets
back but they might have jumped the gun
on that one with porzingis and exactly
they could have maybe used some for
Anthony Davis or held on to Mike you
have a young team of porzingis and
perhaps RJ Barrett joining the team so
it seems like things have backfired
especially you know I don't look too far
from west north of New Jersey and I
don't go a day without somebody telling
me that they ran into Kyrie Irving and
they're asking which team is going to
and everyone that asked him kind of gets
the impression that he's going to the
Brooklyn Nets oh the next but looks like
they don't lose out on that one too
Frank thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time as always Dan
you're the best night I always say when
I be if I was wrong I always think of
you and the great late Jack Ramsay you
guys went tremendous after those games
breaking everything down thank you Frank
that's Frank Isola the athletic ESPN's
around the horn for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]